but it must be interpreted with
extreme caution gains can easily be lost
and there was still an increase in cases
in most other regions of the world
and an increase in deaths
this is no time for complacency
especially with holiday season
approaching in many
cultures and countries we all want to be
together with the people
we love during festive periods
but being with family and friends is not
worth putting them
or yourself at risk
we all need to consider whose life we
might be gambling with
in the decisions we make
the covet 19 pandemic will change the
way we celebrate
but it doesn't mean we can't celebrate
we still can celebrate the changes you
make will depend
on where you live always follow your
local
or national guidelines
the first question to ask yourself is
do you need to travel do you
really need to travel for many people
this is a season for
staying home and staying safe
celebrate with your household and avoid
gatherings with many different
households
and families coming together
if you do meet people from a different
household
meet outdoors if you can maintain
physical distance and wear a mask
avoid crowded shopping centers
shop at less crowded times and use
online shopping if you can
if traveling is essential take
precautions to minimize the risk
for you and others
maintain distance from others and wear a
mask
when you're in airports and train
stations
and on planes trains and buses
carry hand sanitizer with you or wash
your hands frequently with soap and
water
if you feel unwell
don't travel
if we can't celebrate as normal this
year
make a plan to celebrate with your
family and friends
once it's safe to do so
we know it will be safe
it's a matter of time the pandemic will
end
and we all have a part to play in ending
it
and we must remember that for millions
of people
covet 19 is only one health threat
they face on a daily basis
tomorrow is a world aids day
the world has made incredible progress
on hiv aids over the past 10 years
new hiv infections have declined by 23
percent since 2010
and age-related deserts have fallen by
39
percent a record 26 million people are
on
anti-retroviral treatment
but the pace of increase has slowed
and that leaves 20 12 million people who
are living with hiv
but are not on treatment and
12 million is
big that gap is jeopardizing
our goal of ending aids
as a public health threat by 2030
covet 19 has had a profound effect on
people living with hiv
as it has for many diseases
there is some evidence that people
living with hiv may have
an increased risk of severe disease
and deaths from kovid19
this increased risk has been compounded
by disruptions to treatment for people
living with hiv
in a who survey of 127 countries earlier
this year
more than a quarter reported partial
disruption to antiretroviral treatment
for people with hiv however
with support from wha and the work of
health and community workers
the number of countries reporting
disruptions in hiv services has declined
by almost
75 percent since june
this is a good news only nine countries
are still reporting disruptions
and only 12 report a critically low
stock of antiretroviral
medicines this is
mainly due to countries implementing who
guidelines
including providing longer prescriptions
of anti-retrovirals
for three to six months no patients can
avoid health facilities
who has also worked closely with
manufacturers and partners to ensure
adequate
supply of treatment
countries have also introduced a number
of
effective adaptations and innovations
during covet 19.
in africa many countries
have built their testing system
for kobe 19 on the existing lab
infrastructure
for hiv and tb
in thailand the government
has maintained pre-exposure prophylaxis
services
and tele-health counseling for
men who have sex with men
and many countries have introduced more
self-testing for hiv to support
self-care
and avoid the need for people
to visit clinics or
hospitals whoa is urging
urging countries to maintain these
innovations
as part of the new normal and to help
expand testing and treatment
to people who need it
but if the pandemic has taught us
anything
it's that in the face of an urgent
health threat
the world can come together
in new ways to defeat it
for many people the pandemic
is a source of fear but it can also be
a source of hope that we can defeat kobe
19
and we can defeat hiv
and there is a lot of hope
especially with the advent
of the vaccines that have been announced
in the last
few weeks and from who's side
we're sure that we can defeat this
pandemic
using the existing tools and also
the vaccines that are in the pipe line
the most important thing is we need
to have hope
and not only hope
but solidarity to work together
to fight a common enemy using the
existing tools
and also the new announcements of
vaccines
in the pipeline i thank you back to you
margareta grace mille cinquecento annie
dr teddrus uh so now i will open the
floor to questions
as i mentioned before uh dr meg doherty
is here
she's our director of our global hiv
programs to answer your questions
related to
world aids day tomorrow so please take
the advantage
of such expertise we will
um as you know i'm sure use the raise
your right hand
icon to get in the queue to ask your
questions and i would also have to
remind you that we restrict this
question to one
for journalists they are all you have
all been terrific about this
so without further ado i will give the
first question to
carmen from politico come and please
unmute yourself
and go ahead hi margaret thank you
i do have a question for dr mark ryan i
was wondering if you could tell us
at all the way the experts
in the origin virus origin mission were
selected
how many they are and if you can give us
more or less a timeline of when the
names will be made public
thank you um
hi uh i think the names
are public um and the uh
the this election we put out a call i
think to
to to to uh for uh for
for names and suggestions for the team
and the process was to
select a diverse group of individuals
representing a geographically
diverse group who represent the
necessary expertise and that was really
a crown
across veterinary science medical
science
as well as laboratory science and
especially people who would have
uh uh experience of uh investigations at
the animal
uh human interface um i'll pass to to
to maria if she's any supplemental but
it would have been
very much the normal way we pick expert
groups and the way we select
for our missions in trying to balance uh
the need for
the highest quality individuals with
their expertise but also representing a
broad
diversity of geographies to represent
the international community in this
regard maria
there's not really much to add just to
say they are online um we have made them
available online i think they've been up
for a week or two
if if not we can provide the link to if
you don't know where those are
we also have published the terms of
reference for the international team
who have met and who continue to meet to
to make the plans
but as mike has said it's a diverse
group of individuals with
various technical backgrounds a good
geographic representation
to make sure that they have the right
technical background to be able to
assist
in the studies that are needed to
evaluate the virus origins and the
intermediate hosts
yeah thank you uh i'm i mean that's a
very
important question and thank you so much
our colleague from politico
the terms of reference has been
announced
posted the names of experts have been
announced
and i would like to assure you that
who's position is very very clear
we need to know the origin of this virus
because it can help us to prevent
future outbreaks
and we're doing everything
to make sure that we know
the origin
and this is a technical issue
and i would like to say
some have been politicizing this
although we have been doing our best
to know the origin but
some have been politicizing it
what's position has been very clear that
we will start the study from gohan
know what has happened there and then
based on the findings we have there
to explore if there are other avenues
that we have to explore
and our strong has been our position has
been very clear
and very strong
and we're working to make sure that the
origin
is of the virus is known
because it helps the world to understand
the genesis and prevent
future outbreaks
this is not for wh or not work with on
by the way
we're working with fao we're working
with oia
and in the expert team we have
representatives from wha
from fao from oie and we have
international experts from various
countries
from the uk from the united states
from japan from south korea from sudan
you name it but it's already posted
so one thing we would like to advise is
that
please let's not politicize this we're
doing
everything we can based on
signs
and what has been a barrier
and trying to derail us from what we
have been doing scientifically was
the politicization of the study of the
origin of the virus
from some quarters
but tableau is committed to do
everything it can based on science
and solutions to find the origin
and that's the basics we need to do the
basics
and we will not stop from
knowing the truth on the origin of the
virus
but based on science without
politicizing it
or trying to create uh tension
in the in the process and we call upon
everybody actually to cooperate on this
and from our side we will be as
transparent as possible and that's why
we have posted the to ours that's why we
have
posted the list of experts and anything
forward
will be posted openly for you
journalists and others the public to see
there is nothing to hide we want to know
the origin that's it as much as you want
to know the origin of the virus
we do want to know the origin of the
virus
because it will help us to for present
prevent
future outbreaks so i don't want to have
any confusion on it i want you to have
clarity on that our position is
we want to know the origin and we will
do everything
to know the origin please you don't have
you don't need to have
any any confusion on this
thank you
you dr tedros uh the next question
goes to laurent from swiss news laurent
please
unmute yourself and ask your question
thank you margaret this morning uh teams
of uh researchers
from the zurich institute of technology
disclosed a new device that would reduce
the number of uh health workers required
to change the position of a patient in
acu
from back to uh laying a face down
position
from five house workers required to
three
so as in many countries the heads of
icu's have said that the the problem
is not necessary the number of beds but
the number of qualified health workers
uh at their disposal
could that be a game changer and and do
you have other examples of
devices not products that could be
critical in the in the fight against
the pandemic thank you um
thank you i'm not maybe aware but uh i'm
not aware of that but we we do know from
observations of frontline workers that
proning
of patients in intensive care that is
placing them on their fronts and not
their backs
has proved to be a useful way of
helping patients through the most
difficult phase of
their their own response and their own
survival and recovery and i think it's
important to note that
not all innovation happens in distant
labs
and in academic situations a lot of
innovation
comes from observations by frontline
workers trying and testing through
experience seeing what works
seeing what doesn't work and then
sharing those observations with others
and i think we'd like to commend all of
those frontline workers who've done
so much in improving clinical pathways
in general and
improving the standard of care because
what's really helping patients is not
just
specific drugs like dexamethasone if you
look at survival rates
increasing over the last six to 12
months a lot of that has been because
number one we're getting patients who
are likely to deteriorate
into care earlier and that means being
able to monitor and predict who's likely
to become sicker based on underlying
conditions
or their oxygen saturation or their peak
flow or their ability
to to exchange air in their lungs there
are many
uh observations there that have helped
to prioritize patients in the clinical
pathway
um obviously being able to decide which
patients will or won't benefit from
ventilation
or different kinds of respiratory
support the availability of high flow
medical oxygen
and ensuring that people get that in
time there are so many
innovations that have come and these
have come from front line health workers
and teams together
making observations as to what works in
certain circumstances so we will commend
those it is important though that those
observations
are taken beyond that into observational
studies and potentially into trials that
help to
determine exactly what the benefit is
coming from and how to expand that
benefit
into the practice of others we have
living clinical guidelines
one of the things i think that's
remarkable of this response is that
everything is changing so quickly in
clinical practice that we have a living
guideline that's essentially being
updated in real time
with these kinds of of of observations
um again just as an example and
again we we really thank our external
partners
on this the use of medical oxygen is not
just
about oxygen delivery at the site of the
patient it's managing the whole process
of getting oxygen to the healthcare
facility
managing the distribution of oxygen
within that facility
and using that safely and that's
required changes in practice
changes in the supply even down to the
size of tubing
that's been used whether we're using
oxygen in bottles or using oxygen
concentrators
and ensuring that health workers are
trained to use all of that and there's
been a tremendous amount of work done to
really innovate around the supply
of high quality oxygen and make many
countries self-sufficient in the
in the production of medical oxygen for
their own needs
so i would say that this kind of
frontline innovation
is hugely important and again
commending frontline workers for not
only doing the brave thing and the
courageous things that they do
but learning and observing what's
working and then sharing that
with the broader clinical um medical and
nursing community so
maria may wish to add but we can only
welcome initiatives like this we will
definitely look at the if you can reduce
a labor-intensive process such as
pruning the patient
from five to three health workers and
you can do that safely and i add the
words safely
then clearly that's going to be an
innovation that will help
in reducing the demand on on already
exhausted frontline workers maria
yeah thanks mike i'm not aware of that
particular study but just to add that
these innovations that we've seen in in
high income settings low income settings
are really pushing the boundaries of how
we can better care for patients
and might describe that very clearly but
what i do want to say is while we can
increase innovation and while we can
increase our capacity to develop and
produce supplies
we don't have that same ability to
accelerate
the increase in the workforce because
of the training that is required for
individuals to be able to care for
patients
we've seen incredible efforts across the
world to
to have students and medical students um
you know
advance uh you know come forward to to
be able to care for patients and help
supporting in the care of patients
we've seen volunteers come come forward
we've seen retirees come forward come
out of retirement
but i just want to highlight that while
we can increase the innovations and that
is really advancing our ability to keep
to care for patients and to keep health
workers safe we don't have that same
capacity to increase the health
workforce
and i would be remiss if i didn't add
that we need as individuals to do
everything we can to prevent ourselves
from getting infected
and needing to be cared for in a health
facility
we cannot emphasize this enough the
burden on the health care facilities on
health care workers right now
in many countries across the world is
really astounding
while case numbers are declining in a
number of countries the numbers of
deaths are increasing
the demands on health workers are
increasing and so we must do everything
that we can
especially as the director general has
said through the holiday season and into
the new year
do what we can to protect ourselves and
protect our loved ones
um because health workforce right now is
a finite capacity
and we just need to all play our part to
try to prevent
us from needing that that care in the
first place
thank you very much dr van kerkov so the
next question
it comes from goes to john miller of
reuters john could you please
unmute yourself and ask your question
yeah thank you very much for taking my
question um at the outset you talked
about
eliminating unnecessary travel for the
upcoming holidays
there's a broad discussion going on on
among numerous countries in
in europe and beyond about the
appropriateness of holding a ski season
some countries favorite some countries
are opposed to it
in general skiing requires either short
distance or long distance travel
what is the who's position on holding a
ski season and can it be done safely
or should uh countries uh stop skiing
for the year
until there is a solution to the virus
thanks
so thanks for this i can i can start and
maybe mike would like to add here
um in terms of all of these questions
specific to a ski season or specific to
travel or specific to any
um any activity um what who advises is a
risk-based approach
um in terms of what can be done um how
it can be done
um if it can be postponed and if it
can't be postponed how it can be done
safely
skiing is no different um there are
different countries
you know that are that are looking at
whether to keep it open or to close it
whether they can keep it open
in a safe manner but what who has
outlined are ways in which people can
reduce
the opportunities for them to be
infected if the virus is circulating
in an area and if people are in close
contact in that area the virus can
spread it's as simple as that
and so what are the measures that need
to be taken to be able to minimize that
risk
minimize that opportunity for spread so
there are ways in which
different activities can be held
safely or in a more safe manner but
right now there is no zero risk
and while we are definitely seeing some
improvements in
in case incidents in many countries
across europe um it has come at quite
some high cost due to the stay-at-home
measures and the other restrictive
measures that have been put in place
we really need to remain vigilant in
terms of everything that we could do to
prevent that spread
so it needs to be a risk-based approach
in looking at
what policies decision-makers need to be
put in place
taking into account the circulation of
the virus the measures that can be put
in place to keep people physically
distant from one another
to make sure that we we don't give the
virus an opportunity to spread further
yeah i i agree maria this really has to
be a
risk-managed approach and the risk in
this
is not necessarily um skiing itself i
i suspect uh many people won't be
infected for
barreling down the slopes uh in on their
skis
the real issues are going to come at
airports
um on tour on buses taking people to and
from
ski resorts uh ski lifts and places
where
pinch points in in the skiing sort of
experience where people come together in
large numbers
uh and there are pinch points in that uh
not to mention
the apres ski that so many people seem
to enjoy
is another issue so here you're dealing
with issues of airline transport bus
transport the open air closing of bars
it's not just about skiing it's a much
broader issue so i don't think we should
be reducing this down to skiing or ski
seizing
but every government needs to be looking
at is all forms of gatherings
that lead to people congregating are
moving on mass
and how they're going to de-risk those
processes if they don't believe those
processes can be de-risked enough
then curtailing postponing or
managing it in that way and i think
rather than targeting the ski season
the next thing it'll be spring season
and the hiking season and then we'll be
you know
if we had the previous issue in summer
and holiday so i i think rather than
targeting the actual activity it's
important for governments now to look at
the risk management
end-to-end in this process so
governments who are potentially don't
have
skiing as part of their economic
activity may be sending lots of people
to go skiing who may return
with the risk so it's not just the
places in which skiing occurred
it's the aesthetics that's exchanged
between locations
based on the movement of people it's not
that they went skiing or they're going
skiing that's not the issue
the issue is any activity that involves
large numbers of people
moving into a concentrated space and
then using public and other transport to
get there and back
needs to be managed carefully and it
needs to be managed as maria said
with a very much a risk management
approach we don't hold a position on
whether something should be cancelled
or not cancelled because the
circumstances change in each and every
jurisdiction so we would advise that all
countries
look at the their ski seasoning and
other reasons for mass gathering
be they uh sports or recreation
or uh religious and and looks very very
carefully at the end-to-end risks
associated with
with that we are heading in and we are
in the middle of a deep
uh moment of transmission we've seen
great progress made certainly in europe
um over the last number of weeks as the
dg said
with the application of measures however
difficult have reduced and turning
around of that we want to maintain that
progress
um and as we say there are there are
travels
that are needed people may need to
to travel for all kinds of different
reasons the question is whether travel
is considered to be essential or
necessary
and then that i think countries are
going to have to look
at mass recreation and see whether or
not that can be managed
within their current risk management
framework
thank you very much dr ryan and dr van
kerkov so i think we now move from
snow to a tropical regional
brazil because we have bianca from
from globo bianca please unmute yourself
and ask your question
hi margaret can you hear me very well
bianca please go ahead
thanks a lot so yeah here bianca roche
i'm correspondent in switzerland for
global the largest tv network in brazil
and my question is again on brazil
brazil clearly sees an
increase in the number of cases and
deaths
and my my question is probably to mike
and maria what is your main concern with
brazil at this point in time and
technically does see it
as a second wave or is brazil still
facing the first wave thanks
um i think we spoke pretty extensively
about this on friday um
and i think as i said then it's not a
specific concern related to brazil
it's a general concern uh related to
central and south america where many
countries have fought very hard to get
their numbers down
the numbers have not returned to
extremely low levels so many countries
are still
uh moving along with you know with
reasonable but
you know they're not low numbers and the
the difficulty now
is in some countries as they begin to
see a rising number of cases
they need to look at that at national
and sub-national level so even in the
case of brazil
the disease numbers are going down in a
number of states but rising in others so
i think it's about looking at the
problem now
and being very very clear and very very
directed where
where is uh where are cases jumping back
up
what's driving that rise in cases what
can be done at that sub-national level
to deal with that
very much like the the first waves
whether you call this a
a a second wave or a surge within the
first wave
we could be we can have those pedentics
all night
the fact remains that the numbers are
increasing again in a number of
countries and that must be addressed but
that increase
is very unlikely to be everywhere at the
same time it's very likely as it
happened in europe to be occurring in
specific zones
and we need to look at those zones and
see whether or not we can act fast
and implement measures that will be
aimed at suppressing the numbers of
disease
so that the health system stays intact
uh
as it did before and again the the the
the health care workers of brazil did a
fantastic job in during the previous
peak
in maintaining basic capacity of the
health system to deliver
across the country that was a gargantuan
task
so again my advice would be look at the
sub-national level look at where the
increases are occurring
ensure that we have rapid action in
those areas both to contain the disease
and support the health
system um and and we all know the
complexities
of responding uh to covet particularly
in in countries that have both deeply
rural
and very very urbanized settings and
within those urbanized settings a very
different profile
in the population from the very wealthy
to people living
in in slums and and who have very little
access to services so
it's a very diverse situation not no one
size fits all
but we want to avoid the health system
coming under huge pressure
and we want to take action as quickly as
possible in the areas where we see the
disease jumping
back up that does that advice is not
just
for for brazil that that really is for
any country um
facing a a rebound
in in its cases and you'll see in in the
case of europe
um how countries that reacted quickly to
the the
new numbers seem to have done pretty
well in suppressing those numbers and
protecting their house
their health system and now hopefully
with the continued follow through
and we would like to see that follow
through in europe to follow through with
low numbers of cases
and then begin to introduce vaccines if
we have
followed through on low numbers of cases
then other health services can continue
to recover and
meg is here to speak about that from the
perspective of hiv
and we need that we need the system to
be able to not just
survive covet it's got to deliver other
services
and it's got to recover that capacity to
deliver a full service to everybody
and that's will be the same in brazil or
anywhere else so we're not just trying
to get the covert numbers down
for the sake of getting the covert
numbers down we're trying to get the
call with numbers down so the health
system can get back to what it's
supposed to be doing
which is preventing and treating other
diseases um
at the same time uh so the advice goes
for brazil as it goes for everyone else
i don't know
uh marie or meg if you want to add
very very briefly and then i'll pass to
meg um i think that it's the same advice
for all countries as mike has just said
it's tailor the approach
it's look at what your data is telling
you on where the virus is circulating
where the intense activity is
and tailor and target your interventions
to really bring it down further
and then second bring it down keep it
down
follow through we've seen so many
countries that have brought transmission
under control
areas that have brought transmission
under control and they haven't been able
to keep it low because
because of a number of reasons bring it
low keep it low
follow through maintain your vigilance
maintain activities
and really jump on any cases that that
begin
um you know so that they don't have the
opportunity to seed into something
further
and that is advice that is for every
country on every continent of the planet
right now but really it's important that
when you've been able to bring it down
you keep it down meg
thank you very much and i think that's
really quite important right now as
tomorrow we're heading into celebrating
world aids day
and this year the theme of world aids
day is global solidarity
resilience services so i think it really
builds upon the conversation that you're
having here
and also the concern about how what can
we do in either a second
or a third wave or cases because what
we've seen
in at least hiv services is that early
on we saw some dipping in terms of the
number of people getting tested the
number of people getting put onto
treatment
and that can have effects over the long
term of
increased deaths increased new
infections
but we've seen over since june up until
november
sort of a rebound where as the cases are
lower
systems have been able to regroup and
put more people back onto therapy
shore up their arv stocks make sure that
they have adequate supplies
ensure that the health care workers are
doing multiple tasks not only taking
care of cova testing
combining covid and hiv testing with tb
testing so that essentially really that
the healthcare workers can start to
rebuild
and build back better so as we move into
tomorrow
world aids day we also know that many of
the infectious diseases we heard about
malaria today we'll hear about the
reporting in hiv
we're having a bit of a plateau and the
covet on top of that can
can actually increase the sort of
the the the catch up that we need to do
as we start
to have a scenario where we can have
these essential services
working at 100 so we we're really going
to be calling upon health care workers
to in countries and governments to
maintain and
and engage and protect their health care
workers and for hiv that's
particularly important for community-led
and community-based health care workers
as well as nurses and midwives in this
year of the nurse and the midwives
were also as was mentioned earlier
really looking to
take all those innovations that have
come out during covid
whether it's putting more into the hands
of the person person-centered care
having therapies that can go home with
them for three to six months
having self-testing self-collection of
of
tests and or other medicines more of
that can be done as we move forward so
that we can protect
people who need to take their medicines
and people who need to be
coming into the clinic but they don't
have to come in every single time
and lastly we want to ensure that these
disruptions
are maintained that the lack of
disruptions and that the buildback and
disruptions are maintained as we move
forward
i would have to say also there's going
to be always with world aids day some
very exciting news
there's news around new prevention
measures that are going to be available
for people such as the de piverine ring
we have seen news reports around long
acting and jekyll
injectable prevention innovations around
new drugs for
children at very low prices so that the
youngest children can have dahlia tiger
beer
we believe all these innovations have to
come together so that we can actually
work towards ending aids as a public
health threat by 2030.
so um i think that ties it up going back
to maintaining these services
and we're hoping that with the next
waves or or in the spring in the summer
that we won't have to see dips again
where we have to work back
that we maintain the the actual hard
work that all the health care workers
are doing right now to to maintain the
numbers
thanks margarita
okay thank you thank you meg thank you
mike
and maria i just would like to add
one thing because i want brazil to take
it seriously
as you may know the number of cases in
brazil
reached its climax on the week of july
17
which is 319 000
per week which is a record
and then the good news was it was
declining
um the number of cases were declining
until november the week of november 2
which is 114 cases
per week so it's almost
a third of what has been
reported when it reached its climax
but now on
the week of november 26 it's
back again to 100 to 218 000
per week so 319 000
when it reached its climax in july
started to go down
until it reached 114 cases per week in
november 2
and back to 218 000 so from november 2
to november 26 it has again doubled
and the death rate also it has been
declining
until november 2 and now
it's increasing significantly if you
take the
november 2 the week of november 2k days
it's 2538
and now we have 3876
meaning it's a significant increase
between november 2
the week of november 2 and the week of
november 16. that's from 2538 days per
week
to thousand eight hundred seven six days
per week
so i think uh brazil has to be very very
serious
and as what uh mike said
um there are local transmissions that's
fueling and contributing more
but if you see the aggregate
it's very very worrisome thank you
just let me add i agree with the uh
does his comments there but just to make
and and
and human hiv and people in tv and
malaria non-communicable diseases and
the mental health
program and the in the sexual
reproductive health program in
immunization in child health and that's
here
and at country level and out there in
the front line this has been a
hugely demanding 11 months it's one
thing to have to respond to call with
and the resources are there to do that
and the attention is there
it's much harder and it's been much
harder for frontline workers and health
workers and hospital workers
to continue to deliver all of these
other services when the attention and
the resources
and the visibility is all on the other
side of the equation
and the dj has said this many times we
don't get enough
opportunity to thank those who've kept
all of those services going
and kept them ticking over and now are
helping them to recover those services
would not be recovering so quickly
unless people had really kept that
engine running
right the way through the really bad
times in this pandemic so
i think the world we all owe a great
debt of gratitude
to those individuals and teams who've
been non-co-worked working
delivering on those services right the
way through and
they're those workers in my view are
more heroic because
it's harder to be a hero when nobody's
watching
it's harder to be a hero when nobody's
listening
so like it's an opportunity for us
to recognize the role that all of these
services have played right the way
through i know the dg speaks of this all
the time
but uh on the event of you know with uh
world's aids
day tomorrow i think it's time to
celebrate what can be done
and hi aids program and others have led
the way
on things like equity and access and all
these principles that we expound for
covet 19
i think we need to follow the path of of
the programs who've
managed to generate equity and of access
to essential services for these diseases
so thank you
thank you very much and staying on hiv
simon attaba would like to ask a
question on
hiv simon could you unmute yourself and
ask your question
yes thank you margaret thank you for
having me this is simon ateba from today
news africa in washington dc
south africa continues to have the
largest number of people living with hiv
and aids
but over the past decade the country has
made significant progress
it has reduced new transmission by 60
and death by also 60 percent
is there anything that south africa is
doing right
and can we learn anything from
covet 19 to
taco hiv and 8
in in the world thank you
thank you for that question i would have
to say
there's a lot that south africa has done
right and
i think south africa really has to be
congratulated for a bunch
of for much of the work that they've
been doing over the last many years
because they have the largest burden of
people living with hiv
and one one a few examples of what has
gone
really well is a focus on
uh decentralization of their treatment
program
ensuring that it's integrated with
what's considered sort of a nurse-based
approach using community health care
workers
to support the hiv program over the past
year
you've been transitioning to using them
optimal therapy including
tegravir and you've been forerunners in
the work around maternal and child
health reduction of
mother to child transmission through
good anc program and what we call pmtct
programs
as well as finding and treating all of
your children
and testing them to the best of your
abilities
and certainly another area where you're
really standing out is you're starting
to work on prevention
south africa has very high risks among
adolescent girls and young women and i
think this is the time now where south
africa
who has been taking pre-exposure
prophylaxis very seriously
but to really expand that and make sure
that young women young men
have access to good prevention services
including what we call prep
or either a pill depivorine ring
or in the long term and over the next
several years potentially injections
that can protect them from
becoming infected so i have to say on
world aids day
south africa gets a gold star but there
needs to be more work done
and certainly greater coverage attained
to be able to control
and and achieve the the end of aids as a
as a public health threat in the near
future so thank you
thank you very much dr doughty uh the
next question comes from michael from
cnn michael could you
unmute yourself and ask a question
um good morning from british columbia
thank you for taking my question
um a lot of canadians were really jolted
last week when they learned that
the majority of canadians won't be
vaccinated against cloven 19
until as late as december 2021 so
months after people in other g7
countries and a big reason for this is
of course we don't have our own domestic
vaccine production my question
is the following uh given all of the
previous warnings from who and other
experts about a coming global pandemic
do any developed countries have an
excuse to not have better
prepare themselves for provision of ppe
vaccines and
even domestic vaccine production thank
you